u hallo mein name ist herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem video auf
dem kanal dass ich so noch nie gemacht
habe und ich war noch nie so nervös vor
dem 4 wird es bereits im titel
eingeblendet und zwar überrasche ich
heute euch und ich bin ich okay ihr
bereits wisst es am ersten 60 minuten de
eine neue koalition wird vom online
gegangen und hat auch dieses t shirt
hier können im shop punkten und wie
haben sie die letzten tage einige
bestellungen rausgesucht und ich werde
diese besteller jetzt zu hause besuchen
die leute wissen noch gar nichts die
wissen noch nicht bescheid dass wir
kommen das heißt es könnte auch sei das
ist total verwirrt und kein neues
zuhause sind jetzt bei der ersten
adresse angekommen wenn ist übrigens
fällt heute hinten steht auch noch so
ein bobbycar zum hoch auf die bestellung
in der ersten bestellung ist billy aner
werden jetzt mal die jahner überraschen
sie hat einen popsong bestellt
allerdings bekommt jeder der was
bestellt hat heute noch einen
schlüsselanhänger dazu eine signierte
autogrammkarte einen signierten sticker
und ein buch von mir also wir gehen
jetzt mal zu bilden klingelt
[Musik]
intel stellt also bringen ja das hat ja
schon mal sehr gut geklappt die erste
person haben auf jeden fall glücklich
machen können haben uns jetzt gab noch
ein bisschen mit denen der wohnung
unterhalten und so weiter und so fort
also auf jeden fall megacool nochmal
ganz liebe grüße euch hier fahren jetzt
zur nächsten bestellung wir sind jetzt
bei der nächsten person angekommen hier
in köln in der südstadt sehr schöne ecke
und werden jetzt mal schauen ob die auch
zu hause sind wir hatten jetzt
den sonntag frei genommen sondern auch
äußerlich gesucht irgendwie ist also
nicht mehr programm karte auch noch ein
tag dann das seecafé den händen freundin
gehen möchtest dann doch nur noch 110 kg
kann sich noch gleichauf unserer zeitung
zwei dinge haben wir doch noch ein buch
also dass ich mal gab es viele gemacht
habt ihr euch irgendwie senden oder so
damit ihr noch ganz ganz schönen haben
viel spaß gemacht und so schönen sonntag
bisher hat sie mir gesagt ich habe erst
in dieser formation dass keiner strauß
ist ein video machen die sache
das war jetzt die zweite person die wir
heute besucht haben auch mega mega nette
leute also ist echt wahnsinn ich hätte
es nicht gedacht dass es so krass neins
wird ich bin selber immer irgendwie
nervöser als die leute selbst wir
irgendwie sachen bestellt haben aber gut
wir fans auf jeden fall noch zu einer
dritten adressen und schauen ob dort
auch jemand zu hause ist sind angekommen
in dormagen haben hier die bestellung
für die nächste person und schauen ob
die auch zu hause ist
was gestellt hey hallo durchlebt mir
erwartet wird bestellt den shop und wir
machen heute so ein bisschen
weihnachtsmann und bringen die wachen
persönlich vorbei wir noch ein paar
andere sachen eingepackt ja noch zwei
schlüsselanhänger eingepackt 70 meter
ausgegangen karte wir sind nicht froh
dass alle leute zu hause
es kann aber immer geben wird mit dass
leute sind doch keine ahnung wo ich
hoffe die überraschung ist gelungen
gut geklappt also wir sind jetzt gerade
bei der letzten adresse angekommen in
bergheim und was schauen ob die jetzt
auch das wäre so krass überstellt
seine songs nur kurz zur erklärung sein
bruder hatte wurde meinem shop bestellt
weil er selbst am 6
geburtstag hat und da sollte eine
überraschung werden und wir haben die
wahl schon gefasst die mehr oder weniger
kaputt gemacht aber alles gut also er
wusste er bescheid etwas bekommen wird
und ich sitze übrigen halbnackt weil es
zum 30 katzen und ich schwitze wie sonst
wären sie ja gut das weiß die letzte
person die bevor heute besucht haben
haben uns vier adressen die letzten tage
rausgesucht die wir halt so im umkreis
von köln so ein bisschen besuchen
wollten ich weiß auf jeden fall nach
hause und da sehen wir uns jetzt wieder
who leute ich bin wieder zu hause
angekommen und schwitzt wie ein schwein
der heutige tag hat mir einfach mal
wieder gezeigt dass es viel viel schöner
als anderen leuten eine freude zu machen
als sich selbst eine freude zu machen
falls das gerade irgendwie sinn ergibt
es war auf jeden fall megacool einige
von euch jetzt mal zu treffen und quasi
so die richtigen personen hinter den
bestellungen kennenzulernen wie bereits
zu beginn dieses videos hier gesagt dass
meine neue kollektion ja am ersten sechs
in lucka minuspunkte rausgekommen und
dieses t shirt
erst mal dieses looks kilometer t shirt
kann man beispielsweise auch bei mir im
merchandise shop kaufen also schaut gern
mal vorbei
news.de das heutige video hier gefallen
hat dann würde ich nicht sehr sehr sehr
sehr toll über einen daumen hoch von
euch hier unter dem video hier freunde
und leute schreiben wir unbedingt noch
in die kommentare ob ich das ganze
eventuell demnächst nochmal machen soll
denn ich wollte vielleicht am 19 wieder
so limitiert was laune schon vielleicht
noch ein oder zwei produkte und falls
ich euch dann auch noch mal besuchen
soll dann steigst du auf jeden fall
unten in die kommentare wenn ihr bis zum
ersten sind jetzt in ein paar tagen
etwas von den neuen produkten der
ukraine shop.de bestellt dann geht ein
euro von der bestellung an die stiftung
gegen rassismus ich will es auf jeden
fall sehr freuen wenn ihr dort einfach
mal vorbeischauen würde und sagt
berichtet wie die daumen
[Musik]